hallo und willkommen zu ZDF heute live
schön dass ihr bei uns seid Leben unter
russischer Besatzung für die Menschen in
mariopol in der Ukraine ist das seit
mehr als eineinhalb Jahren Alltag ihr
erinnert euch um die Hafenstadt wurde zu
Beginn des russischen Angriffskrieges
erbittert gekämpft die Ukraine musste
sie dann schließlich aufgeben mariopol
verkörpert die Zerstörung dieses Krieges
und das Leid der Menschen in der Ukraine
sie gilt als Symbol für den ukrainischen
Widerstand unser Korrespondent in Moskau
Armin Körper ist nach mariopol gereist
und was er dort erlebt hat was die
Menschen ihm sagen über seine Eindrücke
werden wir gleich mit ihm sprechen
außerdem reden wir mit unserer
reporterin Anne Brühl in Odessa sie wird
uns schildern was ihr Menschen erzählt
haben die aus den besetzten Gebieten
geflohen sind außerdem berichtet sie
über das Schicksal der aus der Ukraine
verschleppten Kinder also Amin und Anne
beantworten gerne eure Fragen schickt
uns einfach eine E-Mail oder schreibt
sie in die Chats wir gehen gleich nach
marioopol Feer fassen uns an Katrin
Maubach und Antoine kurchilgen den
dramatischen Kampf um die Stadt noch mal
zusammen im Frühjahr 2022 verkörpert
eine Stadt das furchtbare Leiden und die
katastrophale Zerstörung des Krieges wie
keine andere die Hafenstadt mariopol
weite Teile der Stadt am asofschen Meer
wurden während der dreimonatigen
Belagerung dem Erdboden gleich gemacht
auch eine Geburtsklinik wird zerstört im
März wird ein Theater im Zentrum
bombardiert in dem hunderte Menschen vor
allem Frauen und Kinder Zuflucht
gefunden hatten die örtlichen Behörden
sprechen von 300 Toten Amnesty
International von einem Kriegsverbrechen
russland lehnt die Verantwortung dafür
ab das Stahlwerk wird zum Symbol des
ukrainischen Widerstands wochenlang
verschanzen sich ukrainische Einheiten
in dem Stahlwerk und verteidigen es die
Russen bombardieren das Gelände fast
täglich am 20 Mai ist der Widerstand
gebrochen tausende ukrainische Soldaten
ergeben sich die russischen Truppen
besetzen das Stahlwerk und die gesamte
Hafenstadt
mariopol Amin Körper in mariopol schönen
guten
Abend hallo meins amen wir haben das
gerade in den Beitrag gesehen in den
ersten Kriegsmonaten hieß es dass die
Stadt fast vollständig zerstört wurde
wie ist dein Eindruck
heute also ich sehe hier sehr viel
Zerstörung man kann das vielleicht sehen
wir stehen hier mitten im Zentrum von
Mariupol hinter mir das ist sind die
zerschossenen Trümmer eines
Einkaufszentrums und sowas sieht man
hier sehr viel in der Stadt Schätzungen
reden da von es sei etwa zwei Drittel
zerstört worden wir sehen aber auch sehr
viel Wiederaufbau es werden Straßen
Schulen Wohnblöcke ganze Wohnviertel
wieder aufgebaut das geht sehr schnell
ich möchte mal vorne weggeben m es ist
Mariupol ist ein Ort kein Ort für für
einfache und klare Antworten auch ich
kann jetzt hier nur meine Eindrücke
sammeln und schildern ich kann jetzt in
den wenigen Tagen wir sind seit
vergangener Woche Mittwoch hier auch für
mich selbst kein vollständiges Bild hier
finden und geschweige den kann ich das
vollständig vermitteln das möchte ich
irgendwie vorne weggeben das sind
irgendwie nur Momentaufnahmen und
Eindrücke was ich hier schildern kann
absolut aber diese Eindrücke sind
wahnsinnig wichtig denn das ist ja
eigentlich mal das Mindeste was man aus
der Stadt hören kann in Ansätzen hast du
die Frage von Gamer 96 schon beantwortet
eben in wie weit mariopol wieder
aufgebaut ist du bist ja unser ZDF
korresponent in Moskau war das denn
kompliziert nach mariopol zu reisen und
daran schließ sich noch eine Frage von
Mark an er möchte gerne wissen konnte
sich das Team frei bewegen und mit den
Menschen sprechen oder war das alles nur
in Anführungszeichen unter russischer
Führung also wir sind völlig unabhängig
alleine unser zdfteam mit dem Auto aus
Moskau über rastof am Don haben wir die
Grenze zur Ukraine überquert und sind
nach Mariupol Gefahren dafür brauchten
wir Einreisepapiere die haben wir von
russischer Seite erhalten ich möchte
ganz deutlich machen dass das nicht
heißt dass wir diese Besatzung von
Russland anerkennen ich denke aber dass
es wichtig ist sich ein Bild vor Ort zu
machen und wenn wir die Gelegenheit
haben dann sollten wir das tun ich halte
das persönlich für wichtig dass man von
dem Krieg von beiden Seiten berichtet
wenn das denn geht und gerade wie wir
das hier heute abend machen das Anne aus
der Ukraine berichtet und ich aus dem
von Russland besetzten Teil der Ukraine
dann haben wir die Zuschauer und
Zuschauer die Chance sich ihr Bild zu
machen und ich denke das ist unsere
Aufgabe auf die Frage aus dem Chat ja
wir können uns hier frei bewegen wir
haben die Einreisepapiere wir werden
aber nicht überwacht zumindest bekomme
ich das nicht mit wir können uns in der
Stadt bewegen können auch Menschen
ansprechen also wir haben da eigentlich
keine Einschränkungen
du sagst du kannst die Menschen
ansprechen wer lebt denn noch in
mariopol und waren die Menschen bereit
dafür waren die offen dafür mit zu
sprechen also diese Stadt hatte bei
Kriegsbeginn ich glaube etwa 450.000
Einwohner man kann das ganz schwer sagen
es gibt keine offiziellen Zahlen
offizielle Zahlen sprechen von 20 bis
80.000 Todesopfern in dieser Stadt man
sagt dass etwa ein Drittel noch hier ist
die die hier sind die sprechen mit denen
können wir problemlos sprechen Mariupol
ist keine Geisterstadt das möchte ich
ganz klar sagen sieht hier Leute auf der
Straße die führen hier ihr Leben und die
sind offen ich habe jetzt eigentlich da
keine Vorbehalte gespürt diejenigen die
wir angesprochen haben die haben auch
mit uns gesprochen es gibt eine Frage
von kremschnitzel aus dem Chat ich weiß
nicht ob du sie beantworten kannst ich
möchte sie dir trotzdem gerne stellen er
fragt wie stehen die jungen Leute zur
Besatzung sind die eher proorussisch
oder eher
proowestlich wie gesagt ich kann nur
mein Eindrücke wiedergeben ich kann
nicht mit jedem Bürger in dieser Stadt
sprechen und wahrscheinlich ist es so
dass die die offen mit uns sprechen eher
die sind die proorussisch sind wenn es
noch Menschen in dieser Stadt gibt die
proowestlich sind dann sind die
wahrscheinlich sehr viel zurückhaltender
und fürchten möglicherweise auch
Repressalien mit uns zu sprechen also
mein Eindruck ist dass die die hier
geblieben sind die jetzt noch da sind
die sind wahrscheinlich mehrheitlich
proussisch wir haben es ja vorhin gesagt
die Stadt wurde weitgehend zerstört man
stellt sich natürlich die Frage die
Wirtschaft lag ja dann auch brach
natürlich wo schlafen diese Menschen wo
arbeiten sie wie leben sie icke fragt
auf Youtube wie ist die humanitäre Krise
dort mittlerweile zu bewerten wie müssen
wir uns das
vorstellen also wie schon gesagt es ist
keine Geisterstadt diese Stadt
funktioniert es gibt Elektrizität es
gibt Heizung es gibt fließendes warmes
Wasser es gibt Internet WLAN das ist
alles da die Menschen führen hier ihr
Leben es sind Geschäfte geöffnet
Restaurants und so weiter große Fabriken
gibt es nicht am Hafen passiert auch
nicht viel
insgesamt ist mein Eindruck oder Zahlen
sagen das auch 80 bis 90% der der
Budgets der besetzten dieser vier
besetzten Regionen in der Ukraine also
durch Russland besetzte Regionen das
sind donjz luuchans und zaporia da sind
etwa 80 bis 90% des Budgets kommen von
Russland also Russland pumpt hier sehr
viel Geld hinein man sagt im vergangenen
Jahr waren das etwa 6 Milliarden
Dollar und wie russisch ist Mario Pol
mittlerweile also ich denke an an
Schulen an Kulturbetriebe wie ist
das also in Mariupol war und ist die
vorherrschende Sprache russisch das war
auch vor dem Krieg so
uns erzählen Menschen wir haben z.B am
Theater gedreht dieses Theater wurde ja
komplett zerstört wir haben damit
schauspielernn gesprochen und so die
erzählen uns dass sie eben in den
letzten Jahren gar nicht russisch
spielen durften jetzt spielen sie wieder
russisch das sind natürlich auch Gründe
für Menschen hier zu bleiben wenn sie
ihre Sprache weiter sprechen können und
in ihrer Sprache arbeiten weil die
Mehrheit der Menschen war hier
muttersprachlich Russisch und ist es
immer noch ich denke das ist schwer zu
sagen wie russisch ist Mariupol in den
Schulen gibt es neue Bücher gibt es neue
Lehrpläne der Geschichtsunterricht all
das folgt jetzt natürlich der russischen
narration das ist ganz klar aber es sind
die Menschen hier also ich spreche mit
wenigen die sich gegen Russland äußern
ist natürlich auch möglichweise
irgendwie eine schwierige Situation für
die Menschen vor Ort sich dann irgendwie
in irgendeiner in andere Richtung zu
äußern ich würde gerne noch ein paar
Fragen aus dem Chat abarbeiten Daniel
fragt sieht man viel Militär und
militärische Checkpoints in der
Stadt ja es ist sehr viel Militär in der
Stadt es sind überall Checkpoints an den
Zugangsstraßen zur Stadt also überhaupt
in den besetzten Gebieten ist sehr viel
russisches Militär Thomas möchte wissen
gibt es ein Partisan was ich noch
ergänzen könnte es ist hier auch eine
Ausgangssperre z.B ab 20 Uhr deutscher
Zeit 22 Uhr hier und dann übernimmt das
mit Militär die Kontrolle über die Stadt
und Thomas möchte wissen gibt es ein
partisanennetz in der Stadt gibt es
Widerstand davon sehe ich nichts also
ich weiß es nicht ich das tritt mir
gegenüber nicht in Erscheinung ich sehe
davon nichts Jonathan möchte wissen was
haben die russischen Besatzer aus dem
Theaterplatz gemacht bzw was ist dort
geplant genau das theater ensemble mit
den Leuten haben wir gesprochen die
spielen zurzeit in der Philharmonie das
Theater wird wieder aufgebaut das eine
große Baustelle soll glaube ich bis Ende
des Jahres wieder aufgebaut werden
Ronald fragt was ist aus den
Massengräbern vor der Stadt geworden die
damals auf den Satellitenbildern zu
erkennen waren kannst du was dazu
sagen genau ich kenne die Bilder auch
von den Massengräbern aus Mariupol ich
sehe hier am Stadtrand sehr viele sehr
große Friedhöfe mit sehr vielen neuen
Gräbern bekommen die Leute in den
besetzten Gebieten z.B Rente oder besser
gesagt welche Leistungen bekommen sie
von den Russen fragt
Wolfgang also sie bekommen russische
Renten ich vermute mal dass die auch ein
bisschen höher sind als sie das in der
Ukraine sind aber das weiß ich jetzt
nicht genau aber Sie bekommen Rente mir
sprach jetzt ich habe mit einer
Rentnerin vor ein paar Tagen gesprochen
die sprag von 100 150 € im Monat
m was sie jetzt vom russischen Staat als
Rente bekommt insgesamt ist halt sehr
auffällig wie viel aufgebaut wird es
werden neue Schulen gebaut es wurde uns
ein topmodernes Krankenhaus vorgeführt
und das ist natürlich alles folgend der
russischen narration natürlich ist für
die Menschen die hier geblieben sind ist
das wichtig dass es Schulen gibt wenn es
moderne Krankenhäuser gibt eine
Gesundheitsversorgung gibt und damit
gewinnt Russland natürlich hier auch
Menschen Russland soll ja die Umsiedlung
von mehreren hunderttaus Menschen nach
mariopol planen siehst du da
irgendwelche Anzeichen
für das sehe ich hier nicht aber das
macht natürlich aus russischer Sicht
Sinn diese Stadt ist es ist etwa
schätzungen zufolge noch ein Drittel der
Bevölkerung hier wenn die Wirtschaft
hier wieder anlaufen soll der Hafen und
so weiter dann braucht es Menschen und
Russland hat natürlich ein Interesse
russische Menschen hier anzusiedeln und
die Russifizierung von
Landstrichen durch das Ansiedeln von
russischen Menschen das ist ja was was
in der Sowjetunion immer wieder passiert
ist und was natürlich Geschichte hier
hat
Amin letzte Frage an dich du sagst es
Leben nicht mehr viele Menschen in
mariopol wer baut denn diese Stadt
überhaupt
auf das sind ganz viele Menschen aus
Russland also auf den Baustellen sehen
wir viele Menschen aus
Zentralasien aber auch wenn wir jetzt
ins Krankenhaus gehen Ärzte Lehrer die
Bauleiter auf den Baustellen das sind
fast alles Menschen aus Russland die zum
Arbeiten hierherkmen Amin ich danke dir
sehr für deine Schilderungen aus
mariopol ich möchte noch von
ulysis auf Youtube einen Kommentar
Vorlesen für dich er schreibt nämlich
danke für den Einsatz unfassbar
mutig danke schön mach's gut amen bis
bald alles Gute
tschüss ja und damit gehen wir direkt
weiter zu unserer Reporterin in Odessa
im Süden in der Ukraine hallo
Anne hallo Anne du hast jetzt wiederum
mit Menschen gesprochen die aus russisch
besetzten Gebieten fliehen konnten oder
deren Heimat von ukrainischen Soldaten
zurückerobert wurde was berichten diese
Menschen von ihrer Zeit unter russisch
Besatzung ja wir haben vor ein paar
Wochen vor zwei Wochen in lewif getret
mit Binnenflüchtlingen es gibt ja hier
in der Ukraine genauso viele Flüchtlinge
wie die die die Ukraine verlassen haben
also das sind Millionen Menschen
sozusagen displaced persons in levv habe
ich gesprochen mit Menschen die
tatsächlich auch aus mariopol kommen aus
beridansk am asofschen Meer in der Nähe
von mariopol und die geschich
die klingen ähnlich eine Flucht unter
großer Gefahr wir haben es ja gehört
mariopol war einige Zeit belagert wurde
dann von den Russen erobert und die Frau
mit der ich gesprochen habe die sagte
wir sind zu FT im Auto geflohen wir
haben geguckt dass wir genügend Benzin
haben jeder von uns hatte nur einen
kleinen Koffer ein Rucksack dabei wir
haben alles zurückgelassen die
Checkpoints der russischen Soldaten
waren schrecklich ihr Mann musste sich
nackt ausziehen an diesen Checkpoints
gibt's auch manchmal Schießereien das
nannte sich damals humanitäre Korridore
aber im Grunde genommen waren das sehr
gefährliche Fluchtwege
diese Frau war sehr erleichtert es dann
nach lewiv geschafft zu haben aber bei
all diesen Geschichten schwingt auch
immer so eine Wehmut mit
auch die Hoffnung wieder in die Heimat
zurückzukehren
ähm die stehen auch in Kontakt mit
Menschen die dort noch geblieben sind
manchmal über Handy manchmal über
soziale Medien es gibt Kontakt und ich
habe natürlich auch gefragt wer ist denn
noch geblieben und und warum sind die
geblieben weil sie sich die Flucht nicht
zugetraut haben ist oft die Antwort und
dass da bleiben eben keineswegs heißt
mit den Russen gemeinsame Sache zu
machen sondern die Geschichten die nach
außen tringen weil ja 18% des
ukrainischen Territoriums noch besetzt
sind das sind immer ähnlich nämlich dass
die Russen versuchen diesen Menschen
russische Pässe aufzuzwingen dass die
ukrainischen Männer teilweise zum
Militär eingezogen werden gezwungen
werden gegen ihr eigenes Land zu kämpfen
von Mord von
Vergewaltigungen Kinder die auch nur mit
einem russischen Pass dann eben in die
Schule
dürfen Patienten die nicht behandelt
werden in Krankenhäusern auch nicht bei
Notfällen wenn sie russische Pässe haben
das sind diese Geschicht die diese
geflohenen aus diesen Gebieten erzählen
und das ist ganz wichtig dass wir dies
jetzt auch noch mal schildern können
denn das sind die Menschen die dann eben
etwas freier vielleicht über ihre
Erlebnisse sprechen können Stefan
schreibt die Bilder die er eben aus
mariopol gesehen hat die erinnern ihn
sehr zum Teil auch an butscha er
schreibt das hat für ihn überhaupt
nichts mehr mit Menschlichkeit zu tun du
hast auch viel über russische Propaganda
in deinen Gesprächen
erfahren wie sieht die aus
na ja eine Frau die aus militopol
geflohen war auch das ist nach wie vor
russisch besetzt die hat mir gesagt die
lokalen Medien die berichten über Sachen
von denen sie weiß dass sie einfach
nicht stimmen sie sagte das ist reine
Propaganda da wird ein russisches
narrativ verbreitet dass die Ukraine
nicht mehr existiert dass die Städte
jetzt russisch sein und sie sagte wir
leben hier oder haben da gelebt und wir
haben ja die Wahrheit gesehen und weil
der Begriff butscha gefallen ist ähm es
gibt ja hier in der Ukraine auch Gebiete
die eben zu Anfang des Kriegs russisch
besetzt waren teilweise einige Wochen
hier rund um Kiev im Norden teilweise
auch länger einige Monate in der Region
hakiv oder hier im Süden um die
Großstadt rasson und es gibt eben viele
dieser Orte wie butscha ja da gibt es
z.B jahitner ein Dorf bei chiev wo die
Russen die komplette Dorfbevölkerung
hunderte von Menschen in den Schulkeller
eingesperrt haben
über eine sehr lange Zeit da sind alte
Menschen gestorben an Sauerstoffmangel
die Leichen durften nicht
da rausbewegt werden isum die Stadt in
der Region hakil die berühmt wurde wegen
der wegen der Massengräber im
Kiefernwald da liegen
449 Leichen die teilweise Folterspuren
aufweisen ich habe in host das ist der
Nachbarort von Butscher eine Frau
getroffen die von den Russen entführt
wurde gefoltert wurde mit einer
Plastiktüte über dem Kopf mit Klebeband
umbunden die danach auf der Straße
rausgeschmissen wurde sie hat gesagt das
war das amageddon sie hatte Angst dass
man sie einfach erschießt sie selbst ist
Ärztin dort in diesem Ort ihr Job ist es
auch die Leichen schau zu machen und sie
sagte sie hat Zivilisten gesehen wo die
Hände auf den Rücken gefesselt waren und
die
in den Hinterkopf geschossen wurden und
das sind die Berichte die die Menschen
hier in der Ukraine kennen und das sind
wirklich ganz viele Fälle 110 000 sagen
die Ukrainer weil die dabei sind diese
Fälle zu dokumentieren und eben den
Russen diese Kriegsverbrechen auch
nachweisen wollen absolut grausame
Schilderungen ein User schreibt mariool
eigentlich eine multikulturelle Stadt
wohl mal gewesen ist sei ein Beispiel
dafür wie hässlich Krieg ist wie ähm
Anne wie betrachtet die Ukraine die
Besatzung von mariopol wird die Stadt
als verloren
angesehen nein überhaupt nicht für die
Ukraine ist das ein russischer
Angriffskrieg
die Territorien sagt die Ukraine sind
Völker rechtswidrig annektiert und
mariopol und auch die anderen Gebiete
der Donbass und die anderen besetzten
Gebiete die werden als Teil der Ukraine
wahrgenommen Präsident selenski sagt
immer der Krieg der hat auf der Krim
begonnen 2014 muss man ja sagen und der
wird auch auf der Krim Enden zum letzten
Unabhängigkeitstag im August war ich
hier und da wurde immer sehr stark
betont dass die Ukraine eben die gesamte
Ukraine ist und dazu zählen diese
Gebiete eben auch
dazu im Zuge der russischen Invasion
sind ja auch tausende ukrainische Kinder
verschleppt worden die ukrainischen
Behörden sagen es sind rund 19 000 du
hast mit einem jungen gesprochen der
verschleppt wurde und mittlerweile
wieder zurück ist in der Ukraine wir
schauen uns seinen Beitrag gerne mal
zusammen an alle sollen wissen was die
Russen gemacht haben sagt uns rostislav
als wir ihn in Kiev treffen er lebt
jetzt in einer Einrichtung für
verschleppte Kinder und Jugendliche
rostislav ist halbweise war 16 als die
Russen sein Dorf bei Cherson besetzten
seine Mutter in die Psychiatrie steckten
und ihn einfach mitnahmen auf die
Krim das Lager hatte den Namen drusba
Freundschaft dort sollten wir jeden Tag
mit der russischen Hymne Aufstehen die
russische Flagge hen und russische
Lieder
singen weil er nicht mitmachen wollte
musste er immer wieder in die
Arrestzelle
viermal sie haben mich beschimpft sie
haben gesagt dass es die Ukraine nicht
mehr gibt dass und Odessa zu Russland
der Weg in die Freiheit gelingt nur
wenigen und soll geheim bleiben denn
noch immer werden rund 19 000 Kinder von
den Russen festgehalten
Anne du h es eindrucksvoll geschildert
tausende Kinder werden noch immer
vermisst was weiß man über deren
Schicksal also welche Bemühungen gibt es
die Kinder zurückzuholen also vieles was
wir ja gerade gesehen haben passiert ja
auch im Verborgenen
ja von einigen kennt man das Schicksal
äh weil die Russen auch Bilder
veröffentlichen wie z.B Kinder in
Sibirien von russischen Eltern adoptiert
werden das sind zum Teil ganz kleine
Kinder von denen man ja auch davon
ausgehen muss dass sie sich irgendwann
eben vielleicht gar nicht mehr an Ihre
richtigen Eltern erinnern können und das
ist ein Verbrechen
das in großer Zahl stattfindet du hast
die Zahl auch genanntch 19500 Fälle
ungefähr 500 Kinder konnten auf
verschlungenen Wegen jetzt wieder in die
Ukraine zurückkehren
es gibt also offenbar
auch Menschen eben in diesen besetzten
Gebieten die
hinter verschlossenen Türen da eben doch
so etwas organisieren wie Hilfe und von
denen man ja ausgehen kann dass sie eben
weiter die Ukraine unterstützen und dann
ist es ja auch ganz wichtig zu sagen ähm
für dieses Verbrechen gibt es ja auch
einen Haftbefehl des Internationalen
Strafgerichtshofs in denhag nämlich für
Vladimir
Putin es gibt noch eine Frage von cersus
dazu er fragt weiß man denn generell
ungefähr wo die Kinder
sind das weiß man eben nicht ich glaube
vor allen Dingen problematisch ist es
wenn die Kinder dann eben äh in Familien
adoptiert werden besonders wenn die auch
eben so klein sind dass sie sich nicht
selbst bei irgendjemand melden können
ähm das ist ein großes Problem ich
glaube was man aber auch weiß und das
war im Fall von rostislav so es gibt
diese Umerziehungslager also das Lager
in dem rostislav war auf der Krim da
waren insgesamt 600 Kinder und
Jugendliche aus der Ukraine
interniert Anne ich danke dir sehr für
deine Schilderung vielen Dank und alles
Gute bis bald tschüss
ja und damit machen wir dann auch
Schluss für heute vielen Dank fürs
zuschauen für die Fragen und die
Kommentare das war ZDF heute live und
wir sehen uns bald wieder bis dann
tschüss